so once again we're gonna replace the
one remaining part of our test that
still has a standard database let's
actually get rid of our database that
leaves us with this lonely insert
statement once again like with
everything else or we'll replace that
with a Content resolver call and of
course we're actually not going to be
inserting the table we're going to be
inserting the content URI getting rid of
the nulls of course this doesn't return
a location row ID that's alright we can
pull it from the URI
using the helper function from content
your eyes we can leave that assert in
there although it's not necessary and
the rest of everything should pretty
much be as it always is we're no longer
using a database at all within test
provider but entirely using the content
provider let's run our tests and see if
they still work and they all pass
congratulations we now have a fully
functioning content provider that can
both insert and query but of course
there are other things you might want to
do with the content provider now we're
not actually going to use any of these
things in sunshine but it's really
important to know so I suggest you
actually implement these functions